[موسيقى]
اكثر من اربعين فنانا من ثلاث عشره دوله
عربيه صعدوا على المسرح في ليله واحده
تكريما للفنان السعودي طلال مداح الذي رحل
قبل اكثر من 22 عاما وبعد اكثر من نصف قرن
من عطائه الفني لا يزال راسخا في ذاكره
عشاقه في السعوديه وعموم العالم العربي
كثيره في الفن السعودي راما احد الاعمده
المهمه في الفن السعودي اذا جينا نؤرخ
للفن للغناء بالذات
والغناء جزء مهم من الفن يعني
طلال مداح
ليله تمر
عط
ريق ورد
[موسيقى]
ليله صوت الارض الحدث الفني الاضخم عربيا
وعالميا اقيمت في الرياض برعايه هيئه
الترفيه السعوديه بحضور الالاف من
الجماهير التي ما زالت تردد اغنيات الراحل
حتى يومنا هذا ومن مختلف الاعمار
سلمت عليه قلت لها ترجي من المسائل الشيخ
فطاربي هو اتحادي فكان يحسبني ولد عبد
المحسن الشيخ الدائم الاتحاد كان غلبان
وقاعد يضحك وحضني اسمحوا لي اغني اغنيه
بالعود بهذا العود اللي احتفظت ابوه 22
سنه وهو الاستاذ طلال
[موسيقى]
وقدمت فيك
حنيني هذه الليله جاءت بعد مبادره رئيس
الهيئه السعوديه للترفيه تركي ال الشيخ
الذي قدم قبل اسابيع دعوه مفتوحه لكل نجوم
السعوديه والخليج والعالم العربي للمشاركه
وهو ما قبل باستجابه اكبر عدد من الفنانين
والفنانات سعوديا وخليجيا وعربيا انتم
ابناء فنان عظيم من حقكم انكم ترفعون
راسكم في بلدكم اليوم في تكريم ابوكم
يا عمر الحزن
شافوني مشغل طلال مداح
فكلن يطلع من عندي ما حد يكلمني يعني اكون
ثاني
[موسيقى]